>> DID RUSSIA GIVE YOU THIS
INFORMATION OR ANYBODY
ASSOCIATED WITH RUSSIA?
>> AL IS NOT A STATE PARTY.
SO THE ANSWER FOR OUR
INTERACTIONS IS NO.
>> YOU DID NOT GET THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DNC, JOHN
PODESTA'S E-MAILS.
CAN YOU TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
1,000% YOU DIDN'T GET IT FROM
RUSSIA OR ANYBODY ASSOCIATED
WITH RUSSIA?
>> WE CAN SAY -- WE HAVE SAID
REPEATEDLY THE LAST TWO MONTHS
THAT OUR SOURCE IS NOT THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT AND IT IS NOT
STATE PARTIES.
>> Sean: THAT WAS WIKILEAKS
FOUNDER JULIAN ASSANGE IN 2017
WHEN WE WENT TO THE ECUADORIAN
EMBASSY IN GREAT BRITAIN.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WILL NOT
STOP AT ANYTHING TO TIE RUSSIAN
TO TRUMP.
AND NOW THEY'RE TURNING TO ROGER
STONE, ONE HEADLINE FROM VICE
NICE READS WHY ROGER STONE COULD
BE MUELLER'S NEXT TARGET.
HERE TO RESPOND HIMSELF,
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST, HE GOT A
FULL FEATURE FOR HIMSELF ON
NETFLIX, ROGER STONE.
HOW ARE YOU, SIR?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, SEAN.
>> Sean: APPRECIATE YOU BEING
BACK.
LET'S START WITH SAM NUNBERG.
A PROTEGE OF YOURS.
I THOUGHT HE WAS EXPLOITED BY
THE MEDIA.
HE DIDN'T SEEM RIGHT.
WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHTS OF HIM?
>> WATCHING THAT INTERVIEW IS
ACROSS BETWEEN HOWARD BEAL AND
NETWORKS SAYING I'M MAD AND AN
ANDY KAUFFMAN ROUTINE.
SAM IS A TALENTED GUY.
HE'S DEALING WITH HIS OWN
DEMONS, CLEARLY.
BUT HE'S NOT SPEAKING AT MY
BEHEST OR WITH ANY DIRECTION.
ON THE HEELS OF HIS INTERVIEWS,
VICE, MSNBC AND OTHERS SAY MY
INDICTMENT IS EMINENT BECAUSE I
RECEIVED HACKED MATERIAL FROM
WIKILEAKS OR JULIAN ASSANGE AND
GAVE IT TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND DONALD TRUMP.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT SEAN IS, I
RECEIVED -- NEVER RECEIVED
ANYTHING WHATSOEVER.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
I HAD NO ADVANCE NOTICE OF
CONTENT, SOURCE OR EXACT TIMING
OF WIKILEAKS DISCLOSURES
REGARDING THE DNC OR HILLARY
CLINTON.
I NEVER RECEIVED ANY MATERIAL
FROM WIKILEAKS OR THE RUSSIAN
STATE OR ANYBODY ELSE THEREFORE
I COULDN'T HAVE PASS IT ON TO
ANYBODY IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND I NEVER DISCUSSED WIKILEAKS
DISCLOSURES WITH CANDIDATE TRUMP
OR PRESIDENT TRUMP BEFORE,
DURING OR AFTER THE CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: HAVE YOU BEEN
SUBPOENAED BY ROBERT MUELLER?
>> I HAVE NOT.
BUT BASED ON A "NEW YORK TIMES"
STORY OF JANUARY 20th, 2017,
INAUGURATION DAY THAT SAID THAT
MY COMMUNICATIONS WERE ALONG
WITH PAUL MANAFORT AND CARTER
PAGE BEING SURVEILLED UNDER A
FISA WARRANT, I HAVE OPERATED ON
THE ASSUMPTION THAT SOME
AUTHORITIES HAVE BEEN MONITORING
MY COMMUNICATIONS THE ENTIRE
TIME.
I HAVE NO EVIDENCE OR KNOWLEDGE
OR INVOLVEMENT IN RUSSIAN
COLLUSION OR ANYTHING OTHER
INAPPROPRIATE ACT.
>> Sean: I MIGHT BE THE ONLY
PERSON IN AMERICA THAT HAS
ACTUALLY INTERVIEWED JULIAN
ASSANGE FIVE TIMES.
I DID GO TO THE ECUADORIAN
EMBASSY.
SOME PEOPLE LIKE HIM, SOME
PEOPLE DON'T.
IT'S IRRELEVANT.
HE PUT THE E-MAILS IN PLAY.
HE REVEALED THE E-MAILS TO THE
WORLD.
THE QUESTION THAT I THINK WE'VE
GOT TO ASK OURSELVES, IF ROBERT
MUELLER, IF HIS MANDATE, WHICH
IS NOW EXPANDED EVEN INTO THE
UAE AND WELL BEYOND WHAT HIS
ORIGINAL MANDATE IS, IF HIS
MANDATE IS TO DISCOVER TRUMP
RUSSIA COLLUSION, WHERE THE
E-MAILS CAME, FROM DID THEY COME
FROM RUSSIA, DON'T YOU THINK THE
FIRST GUY YOU MIGHT WANT TO ASK
OR TRY TO GET INFORMATION FROM
WOULD BE THE GUY THAT WE -- THE
ONE PERSON ON EARTH THAT YOU
KNOW KNOWS WHERE THAT CAME FROM?
WHETHER YOU LIKE JULIAN OR DON'T
LIKE JULIAN, THAT WOULD BE
JULIAN ASSANGE.
I CAN SAY WITH CERTAINTY ANYBODY
ELSE ON THE FACE OF THIS EARTH
WOULD KNOW 100%, BUT HE WOULD.
>> WELL, WHEN I SAID ON MSNBC
TONIGHT THAT I DID NOT BELIEVE
THAT JULIAN ASSANGE WAS A
RUSSIAN AGENT AND I DIDN'T
BELIEVE THAT WIKILEAKS IS A
RUSSIAN ASSET, I THINK HE'S AN
HONEST JOURNALIST.
NOBODY HAS QUESTIONED THE
ACCURACY OF ANY OF THE MATERIALS
THAT WIKILEAKS HAS RELEASED.
>> Sean: 11 YEARS --
>> THEIR WHOLE PROMISE -- THEIR
FALSE PREMISE --
>> Sean: 11 YEARS THEY'VE NEVER
GOTTEN A THING WRONG.
THAT'S BETTER THAN MSNBC, CNN
AND "WASHINGTON POST" AND THE
TIMES.
NOT ONE THAT THEY HAVE GOTTEN
WRONG.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS ENTIRE NARRATIVE IS BASED
ON A FALSE PREMISE FROM OUR
POLITICIZED INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES THAT JULIAN ASSANGE IS
A RUSSIAN AGENT.
NO, HE'S A JOURNALIST THAT HAS
AN INCREDIBLE RECORD FOR
ACCURACY AND AUTHENTICITY.
WHEN YOU REJECT THAT AT MSNBC,
THEY SAY STONE IS MOVING THE
GOAL POST.
NO, I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR
TWO YEARS.
I CONTINUE TO BELIEVE IT.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT TELL YOU,
THERE'S NO MET DA DATA
COLLECTION PROGRAM ON AMERICANS
OR SADDAM HUSSEIN HAS WEAPONS OF
MASS DESTRUCTION.
THEY INSIST JULIAN ASSANGE IS A
RUSSIAN ASSET.
I BELIEVE THAT IS FALSE.
>> WE KNOW THAT PETER STRZOK